- Niqi where are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- I was actually born in
the Balboa Naval Hospital.
My dad was in the Navy,
but that was short-lived.
And then I moved to Long beach
and I've been pretty much everywhere
that you could think of.
My mom and my dad split
when I was very young
'cause my dad used to do
drugs and beat on my mom and
so they separated and
my mom was a single mom.
I have brothers and I'm the
only girl and the oldest.
So then my mom became an addict
and I became mom slash sisters
slash aunt slash babysitter
for all my mom's home
grows and their children,
so I'm nine years old and a child myself
and knew how to make mixed drinks and
pick up my drunk mom off the floor
and take care of my brothers.
And we were really poor,
like really poor people say,
Oh we were poor when we grew up.
But, and then I hear what they say
and how they're they live their life.
And no poor, we were poor.
Like we used, we would wet magazine
you know what I mean?
And wipe our butts sometimes,
like electricity would be off.
I remember being nine years old
and walking from door to door
asking different neighbors
for different things
so I could feed me and my
brothers in that kind of poor.
And then I learned how to steal
and that like saved my family.
My mom even knew that I was stealing
but she was so far in her addiction that
she didn't even care.
And she somehow made it right to herself.
Well, God knows, God knows our heart
I remember she used to say that and
she sold me for a dope sack
when I was 12 to her boyfriend's brother.
That's when pretty much
my life had took a turn
because my innocence was
taken from me at that time.
(crying)
Am sorry.
And so then after that point,
I just, I'm 12 years old
and really didn't know
too much about life.
I knew that as far as I was concerned
life was rough but because
that's all I had been through
I didn't even really realize
that what I was going
through was abnormal until
I started hanging out
with people who had normal lives.
But then, because I was so
used to having chaos around me
that that would only be short-lived,
I could only hang out with my
normal friends for so long.
And I had to hang out with gang members
and people who were older than me.
And because that's just,
it was normal to me
the white fence, white picket fence
and that was never anything that
I ever thought that I
would be able to obtain.
But yeah that's how I grew up.
And then when I got a
little bit older, like
so because I was so angry, right.
I got kicked out of several schools
became a gang member was very promiscuous
'cause that was normal.
Plus I didn't have a dad
my mom was promiscuous
my mom was an addict.
So seeing all those things for so long,
it just kind of rubs off on.
And I got kicked out like eight schools
and like kicked out of
the Orange County district
because I had gotten sent to
Orange County from Long beach
and eventually I had
to become homeschooled.
And of course that didn't work well
because I already didn't
have any guidance.
I finally graduated high school
in County jail when I was 25,
never was really interested
in anything that was successful ever.
I always had an interest in
it always looked good to me
but I think somehow there
was something on the inside
of me that felt that maybe
I didn't deserve success.
So always self-sabotage always
my whole entire life including now.
Excuse me gonna have to take
a shot like, I'm so sorry.
Alcoholism is very ugly, but it's real.
- [Interviewer] That's vodka orange juice?
- Yeah, but I don't like to mix it
'cause for somehow for
some reason it feels
like it's less potent that way
I need to feel the burn I guess.
What I do remember is
'cause I've always been smart,
I think maybe it's because I had to
be an adult at an early age.
And I know during junior
high and high school
teachers would try to send
me to leadership classes
and they would tell my mom
who would always be high
as a fucking kite when she would go
to my parent teacher conferences
if she would even show up.
She's so brilliant, she's
very sharp, she's smart.
She just doesn't apply herself.
Is there anything that's going on at home
Well, yeah, I mean, she
doesn't have electricity
and sometimes she goes to sleep
without eating and
I smoked crack and fuck five
different men during the week.
No, that was never said.
I had this...
Somehow my mom gave me the
reputation that she gave me
because she couldn't
dare say that it was her.
So she made me the bad kid
and I became the bad kid.
I was always chubby.
So that was rough for me.
So instead of
dealing with the fat jokes
or whatever the case may be
I started bullying others
and I would make fun of myself first.
So, or there's one to
have a chance to do it.
I would act like it didn't matter.
But because I was so used
to being the fat whore
or whatever from my
mother the one person that
the one person better than everybody
in your whole entire life,
that you would think.
Hey, you can trust in
love, betrays you like that
and does the things that they do.
The way that you look at, other people
just believe said, it's a
different for your life.
You don't trust anybody and
you have your guards up, like
I can't even believe that
I'm sharing this things.
But
so became that kid in
and out of juvenile hall.
Would always fight I was
very violent, very violent
because that's the way that,
because I was beaten
and raped and molested
and I was so angry,
I was so angry I hated my mother.
I still hate my mom and that's sad
but I love her at the same time.
And nobody could ever
say anything about my mom
'cause I would beat their ass.
But yeah.
That's like the gist of my, I mean
and I've always been talented and
I sing, I've always had a gift.
Like I could sing my ass off.
My mom stopped me from
doing a lot of things
either because she didn't wanna pay for it
or when I was like 14 years old
she decided to be a born
again, Christian right.
And then she decided to,
well you spare the rod,
you spoil the child.
And then she thought that she
could beat me and my brothers.
And it was okay because
that's what the Bible says
but bitch we've already been grown now
we've raised ourselves.
You wanna try to hit us now
we've already been through too much.
Who the fuck do you think you are?
But I do remember as a child,
I felt the power of God.
And it didn't change the way
that I felt about the Lord.
And I realized at that point
in time that you know what
I do have a gift and I do love God.
So like I've been through
almost every aspect
of life you could think of.
And so even though my
mom was fucking the usher
who was married
and wondered why people
looked at her crazy and shit
and they used to do meth on the weekends
when nobody was looking but God was.
And so I like prided
myself in being different.
I didn't wanna have sex before marriage.
I didn't wanna, I wanted
to do it the right way.
I started doing good in school and
was actually on the honor
roll for a little while.
But then after I became home
like I lost all hope right
after my grandma died, my grandma died.
And my grandma was the only person that
was the rock in my family.
My mom came from a family of 10,
she had 10 brothers and sisters,
her brothers and sisters,
they were all abusive to each other.
And that's because my grandpa
was a raging alcoholic
go figure he actually died
of cirrhosis of the liver
not too long ago.
And he used to beat my grandmother
who was the most awesome lady.
It's some people who are changed
by their atmosphere and
in what they go through
and some people are not my
grandma was never changed.
It didn't matter.
Didn't matter how much
shit she went through.
She was never changed
but everybody else was.
After my grandma died and I no longer had,
'cause my grandma would
put my mom in check.
My grandma would say Teris
no, no, no, no, no, no.
You need to let her
aspire and being a singer
and she's gotta be somebody
and you can't treat her that way.
And I would never tell my
grandma exactly what she did
because even though my mom
did some up fucked up shit
I didn't want my grandma
to be mad at my mom
because I didn't want
my mom to be mad at me
because I always strive
for her approval still.
And that's basically
where the hurt starts.
The hurt started there
and it didn't end there.
- When did you...
When you left your mom's
house, where did you go?
- I had been in and out of my mom's house
since I was 14 years old.
- So at 14 you right away?
- Yeah.
- Did you finish high school?
- When I got my GED in jail at 25,
never finished I was too busy
drinking and gang-banging and
trying to be accepted
because the neighborhood that I grew up in
was predominantly black and Hispanic
and I'm Egyptian and French.
But I look like a white girl.
And so I had to be harder than them
and little did they
know that I was angrier
than a lot of them
so it didn't really take much for me.
And then I was accepted
and I actually had a family sounds stupid
but they were my family.
And as far as I was concerned,
we would die for each other.
That's not the fucking truth
gang members most of the
time, they're only loyal
to each other to a fault
and to a certain extent.
And once what they need from you
or what they want from you
is over their loyalty
becomes less and less.
Don't get me wrong.
There are some people that keep it family
and when you go to jail,
they're there for you.
But at the end of the day
you're the one that does that time.
You're the one that's in
that cell all by yourself
because you're a violent offender.
You're the one who doesn't
have anybody writing you.
You're the one that doesn't have anybody
accepting your phone calls
so you're just alone.
And then you're around all
these different criminals
and it makes you even more
angry and a better criminal
'cause what happens when
you get a whole bunch
of people who have made mistakes,
you trade each other's mistakes
and you become a better criminal.
And that's what happens
and it's crazy but it's
just a vicious cycle.
I don't even, I don't
believe in the jail system.
I don't believe in the judicial system
because they're not for
us, they're really not.
And what happens to an
animal when you cage somebody
they either fight or they flight.
And if there's nowhere to fucking run
you have no other choice but to fight.
And then that makes you harder.
- What kind of stuff were you doing
when you were on your own?
- When I was what.
- When you had left your mom's house
and you were on your own,
what were you doing for money,
what did you do with your time?
- Oh, God
selling drugs, doing drugs,
selling pussy,
stealing because I really
because I was a gang
member and I had pride
that the selling pussy part
came way later in life.
'Cause I thought that hoes were
just disgusting at the time.
I had no idea that that's a
whole different aspect of life.
And, but anyway, but for the most part
because I was one of the youngest,
you can go from pillar to post
'cause you're young and you're hurting
and your mom is so fucked up that
people actually care
then when you're young
and it was a long time
ago, I'm 40 years old.
People actually had a lot
more care for people then
because everything wasn't
done on video and online
you actually had to have a
conversation with people and
I mean, I remember being younger and
especially cause I have had friends,
I have I've had friends
who were gang members
or whatever the case may be
and had really good lives.
Like what the fuck are you doing?
You don't even belong here like.
This is not for you.
This is for people.
This is for people who have no family
and who are hurting and who are rough like
There's a lot of that out here
to a lot of that out here.
And I say that to those people to, like
what the fuck are you doing out here?
You have a family, you
have a fucking career.
You have so many things that you
so many other things
that you could be doing
like wish I could see my kids
but my rights got taken.
I haven't see my kids in three years
and my baby is almost four.
You know what happens to person
I'm a woman and a mother.
When there kids are taken
you take away the reason
to wake up every day,
God I'm jumping from high school
to how I ended up out here.
Three years ago almost lived in Las Vegas
'cause I actually did
I actually did make of
myself for a little while.
Off and on I've had success
and then I fucked it up
and then I've had success
and then I fucked it up through alcoholism
and self-sabotage like I say.
I had a beautiful home
in Las Vegas, a career.
I was modeling on the
side, singing in studios.
I had all my kids with me, two cars
like life was good for me.
My baby's dad came to Las Vegas
and picked a fight with me
and violence is you put me
in a corner, I'm gonna fight.
It doesn't matter whether I lose or win
you're gonna get hit fucking with me.
- It's just, five brothers, rough life.
This just happens
but so I hit him right.
And even though the kids were not awake
they were not even in the same room.
They were across the house a sleep
a neighbor called because
of his disturbance.
And Nevada does not play
like their laws are super strict.
And because I already had a
strike and a violent crime
They wanted a mimic his
back and my mom decided,
Hey I'll take 'em and go take care
of everything that you
need to take care of.
And I'll give them back to you, Niqi.
When my kids first got taken
'cause all I knew right.
Had everything up in my life
the one good thing that
I did have where my kids
and I pride myself on being a good mom.
When I tried my damnedest to
be the best mom that I could
and I was a good mom
And I didn't sleep for nine days Mark
because every time I...
'Cause my baby was just a baby
when he was first taken, I have three.
But my youngest was just a baby.
He was the only one he
had just turned one.
He slept with me every day.
And so every time I tried to close my eyes
I couldn't sleep because they
didn't feel complete one.
And then like oppression
just took over depression
I would close my eyes I
would hear my baby cry.
It was like, I was almost being tormented.
I mean, I don't know if you
believe in spirits or whatever
but it really felt like
I was being tormented by evil spirits.
And nine days later, I guess
from, another disturbance
my fucking neighbors were nosy as hell.
Las Vegas PD came into my
house and they had a break in
'cause at this point I'm
comatose but I wasn't sleeping.
And when they walked in,
I was sitting at the table
with a gun Carla Rossi in front of me
and for dinner plates at the table.
'Cause I was taking care
of kids that weren't there.
I guess my body had autopilot,
and losing them was
just traumatic to me so,
and then I was in the Las
Vegas mental institution
for two and a half weeks.
And then they finally
decided to let me out.
And I went back to my apartment
and I packed up everything
that I could in my little car.
And I went back to the abuser
and the abused, baby's dad.
And he was methed out,
swore that he would help
me get the kids back.
he didn't wanna help me.
And so my addiction and his addiction
just became stronger and stronger.
And then we became more and
more abusive to each other
to the point where we both went to jail
for domestic violence,
again, lost everything.
So I get out of jail.
My mom had changed her phone number.
I didn't know where my kids were.
So I felt like, okay, well fuck it.
I really have nothing and nobody.
So what do I do now?
So I really went on destructive mode
to the point where I like wanted to die
and wanted to kill myself
and tried many times.
And for some reason there's something that
something or someone that always stops me.
I wouldn't wish some of the things
that I've been through
and seen on anybody.
So I got into prostitution because
being on the street at
this point is dangerous.
And this is when I first became homeless
and I had to add a pimp.
And he was the one who was like,
hey well you like to fuck anyway.
So you might as well make money doing it.
And so I started selling myself
and I made good money doing it
but I didn't get to keep
any of it of course.
And you know there's all these promises
that are given to you.
Yeah, we'll do this and we'll
help you get your kids back.
And so of course,
I give my all and I gotta hate forever.
I have nothing to show for
it, nothing, but I did.
I did have a contusion, broken ribs
no shoes and a busted lip.
By the time I finally got
out of that situation almost a year later.
And I got out of that through CAST
which is a coalition
against sexual trafficking.
They brought me out here
because where I was being
trafficked was in Orange County.
So they brought me out here.
Their main office is actually out here
and they put me in a hotel downtown.
Next thing I met a cute guy who told me
that he had a hotel and
he'd be able to help me.
And I'm so beautiful and
dah, dah, dah, and talented.
And I ended up on fucking Agatha.
And I've been out here since Ms.
almost three years ago,
it's almost like skid row
was it Twilight zone.
And because most of the
people here are so helpless
and hopeless and hurting so badly.
And it's so dog eat dog out here
and hurting people, hurt people.
I've been raped three times.
I was kidnapped for three days.
Fuck and it seems like
every time I get a head,
even just a little bit
I get knocked back like steps.
And a lot of the men out here
are just fucking, they are predators
and they'll use anything, love, kids,
Shelter, anything.
To get what it is that they want from you.
And then once they get what they want
they just throw you away
like a piece of trash.
And then if you decide not to,
you end up like me angry,
bitter, in the cold, sick.
Last year it was so cold
during the winter time I lost
I had gotten pneumonia and
lost hearing in my right ear.
So it's like fuck you're damned
if you do damned if you don't
and then you get paperwork ready.
So you could try to get an SRO
and somebody steers your foot
in person, then you're
starting all over again.
And it's hard to do anyway.
'Cause guess what?
You stay up all night.
So you don't have to be subjected
to anybody else's bullshit
so you're tired as fuck
by the time the day comes.
So you do drugs to stay awake
and because you do judge stay awake
and you've been awake all night.
You don't wanna go and
take care of any business
that's the last thing that's on your mind.
And so it's just another
vicious cycle all over again.
It's like, God,
I wish that God would just
really just put his hand
down and just do something
about this cesspool of pain.
And there's a lot of there's people
from all different types of life out here
people who were very successful,
people who have had careers
and lives and down to the dirtiest,
like it's people who are very talented.
I've seen so many talented
people out here Mark
is a damn shame,
I wish He would just put
his hand down and just help.
Help there are hurting people out here
and hurting people, hurt people.
It's a known fact
psychologically like, mentally
emotionally, like if you've
been through some shit
and you're hurting, you're
either gonna have your
guards up so much to the
point where you don't care
or you're gonna hurt others, period.
I mean, I wish at least somebody would be
on some Robin hood shit
where they could steal from
the rich and give to the poor.
But all these poor people
are stealing from each other
and hurting each other and
selling drugs to each other.
Fuck, it's like another world out here.
I know you've seen it.
How can all of society
just go on around us
and nobody see what's going on.
Does that make sense?
And so is it as if it's
some kind of conspiracy
- It's just too painful to look at
too painful for the process
for a lot of people.
- How they're the, shame on
you to just turn your face
and go on with your fucking life
while people are dying out here,
three people just this year
have died from hypothermia.
'Cause it's cold out here.
There are parasites and bugs and disease
and everybody's having sex with
each other and there's AIDS.
And like, it's...
We're all gonna die.
- Not to mention the fentanyl
- The fentanyl and the
heroin and overdose is like
we're all gonna die
unless we get outta here.
I mean, what is it,
population control what is it?
I just, I don't understand
but I don't want this to be my legacy.
'Cause one day my kids
will get older right.
I don't want them to come
down here and have their mama
meet me like being fucking cracked out
like some of the girls that I see, no.
I don't want that for myself.
And I still try, which is
something that I pride in myself.
That I've never given up
no matter how much I've been through.
I can't...
Even though it may look
like it on the outside
there's something on the
inside of me that won't give up
and that's usually just human nature
because we're animals and animals fight.
It's nature.
The drugs numb you
to the point where you
just lose the fight.
You just, you lose the fight
and it makes me so sad to see
people that lose their drive.
Fuck I mean, I'm an alcoholic
and that's one of that's like the worst.
It really, really is.
It's everywhere.
And if you don't use it, it
makes you sick and you can die.
So even though people can look at it like,
Oh well you could just quit.
Just don't drink.
Well bitch you just don't buy the sack.
Like how dare you talk about my addiction,
but I, you can actually
have a seizure and die.
Alcohol is the only thing that
if you go to jail,
It's the only thing that they give you
detox medicine for anymore.
They don't even give heroin
addicts, detox medicine.
'Cause even though their body hurts
and their body is addicted to it too
they can live without it.
Alcohol is the only thing that
you actually need medicine for.
And it's so sad and I hate it.
Every time I take a drink, I hate it.
It's almost like the devil.
There are some times where
I go to where they sell shots
in the morning 'cause I'm shaking
and I have the DTS and
I'm actually, I cry I weep
when I'm taking the first shot.
'Cause am like fuck here we go again.
But you need it.
So, you know you gotta take it.
And you're like damn.
How did my life ended up like this?
And you have people who tell
you, you're so beautiful.
You're so talented.
You're so smart.
Why are you here?
I've heard that too.
I don't know.
I guess you don't see it.
You don't see what
other people see in you.
And I had somebody tell me the other day
and actually broke my heart.
They told me, queen, you're
letting this place change you
well dah, I mean fuck,
it's inevitable that
that's gonna happen
but they said you don't
the light that you used
to have in your eyes
isn't there anymore.
And I think that that's
part of the dog eat dog.
So like there's two sides.
There's either good or evil.
There's no gray area.
It's either good or it's bad.
And if there's no good around you
and there's no good going on
what other choice you have.
And then next thing you know,
you find yourself
becoming darker and darker
and meaner and meaner.
And they were right.
My light doesn't shine
the way that it used to.
And I don't even get
drunk anymore damn it.
You can't, I can't even enjoy
my drug, which is fucked up.
I'm only drinking to just survive.
At least these other motherfuckers get to
not off damn you.
- Do you talk to your kids though?
- No, I haven't talked
to them or seen them.
- If you could talk to
them, what would you say?
- Damn Mark for real.
I love them and I miss them very much
and I know that mommy fucked up right.
And if I could change it at all, I would,
but just know that I never, ever, ever
wanted this to happen.
And please don't feel like I abandoned you
because that's not what
happened I never left you.
You were taken there's a difference.
And they were the best thing
that ever happened to me.
Yeah, they saved my life
Even though it's a fucked up one.
'Cause if it wasn't for
them, I would have been dead.
Yeah that's what I would say to them.
- When you boil it down,
what do you think the
core of your problem is?
- God, that would make it
to where I would blame
everything on my mom.
No, I can't do that.
Anger,
I would say anger.
Because it's a
Anger and hurt I mean,
'cause there's stages to pain
and once it turns into anger
then there's rage and there's
no coming back from that.
I would say being angry
and not having anybody to talk to
or anybody to relate to
because they give you programs
and fucking try to put
you in counseling and shit
but this motherfucker has a PhD
and has never been through anything.
They need more advocates
they need more people who have actually
been through some shit.
Because if you've never
actually been through it
you can't reach people the way
that somebody act that actually has,
Just like I believe 'cause
like I said, I'm a singer
I believe that if you
haven't actually been
through what you're singing about
you shouldn't be singing that shit.
So how are you gonna teach me about
how to fix my fucking life
if you haven't been through
the shit to fix your life.
Right?
Yeah, having the lack of
having a lack of resources
probably an anger
being so angry and not
knowing how to release it.
And so finding other ways
to release pain and rage
through sex and drugs
and music and alcohol
and all the numb shit.
As long as I'm not
feeling it, I don't care.
That's one of my things out here,
as long as I have music in my alcohol
and some cigarettes I'm okay.
And for a little while, that's true.
But then it gets cold and your alone
And then you realize
fuck, I'm really alone.
And that's one of the most painful things.
'Cause there's a lot of like
disturbing relationships out here.
I don't want that.
I knew bad all by myself Mark.
We need anybody to help me
do that but it's lonely.
And everybody thinks that,
Oh man, I know you gotta
I know you gotta gang motherfuckers on you
you're so pretty and...
No, of course they're all on me
but all they want is one thing.
And I don't want that for me
Unless you're gonna love me
for all of my fucking bullshit
and all the things that I've been through
which is a big job.
So if I ever do find that somebody's right
they're gonna have to
love me through some shit
and cheers to them.
But once they get through
all of that stuff,
I'm an amazing woman.
And they'll be blessed.
And the scrutiny that I
still believe in that,
even being in through seeing
all this shit that I see
I wish I could take the camera right now
and show you where the I'm at.
But through being through
all this that I lived through
I still believe in love
when I see somebody and
I'm walking down the street
and I see them in the gutter.
I tell get the fuck up, get
up, get your ass up, man.
Like, come on there's you
can't go out like this
not in the gutter, dude.
Put your shoes on bitch.
Like have some pride in yourself.
Crazy huh and I still believe
but I still believe you never know.
Maybe all these things
that I'm going through
is for somebody else.
Maybe that's the reason
why you met me today
'cause somebody out there needs to hear
that they can make it
and please don't make the same mistakes
because you might end up here
and not everybody is strong.
I consider myself very strong
not everybody's strong
enough to live through this.
- Niqi thank you for coming in.
- Thank you for having me.
Thank you for what you're doing.
We need more Marks in the world.
Shit my alcohol is gone.
- I'll give you money for more
- Okay.
Thank you for what you doing.